ian what's your thoughts what are your
impressions on everything unfolding here
in green bay
first of all i'm surprised you're still
getting to me um
because basically everyone in the world
is
watching aaron rodgers just sit there
and essentially say everything he has
wanted to say for the last three months
publicly sitting at this press
conference i mean it is
truly unbelievable honestly and like you
know some of this stuff's been reported
some of this stuff is not i think we've
known he wanted to be more involved we'd
known his frustration with
the jordy nelsons and randall cobbs got
cut we knew jake kumaro
pissed him off when when he was released
but to see aaron rodgers sit there and
in you know these
uh many moments many many raw moments
of just openness is truly astounding um
it's it's incredible um it is everything
that was necessary maybe there will be a
cleansing
um in green bay and uh yeah it's pretty
incredible
tom pelisaro put on twitter that aaron
is saying i know i can still play and i
want to still play and
talk about how at the same time brett
favre said goodbye with the words i know
i can play but
i don't think i want to what's the
magnitude of this
if you look at the big picture of the
nfl and this
dayton between the packers and aaron
rodgers
what does that all mean well it means
that aaron rodgers is going to be the
packers quarterback this year
and then that's all that we know which
is okay because i think most players in
the nfl are year to year
you know maybe you get a big five-year
contract and you know you're going to be
there three years but
sometimes it means you're only going to
be there two years so rogers we know
he's going to be there one year
it also means for those people who
enjoy talking about things like where's
aaron rodgers or where's russell wilson
going to go
we're probably going to do it again next
offseason but you know it's amazing that
it sort of came together
like it did i think the packers you know
probably did a good job
uh when it became public very public
and said we need to listen to this guy
like we you know because they
traditionally the packers have treated
players like players
and as rogers very clearly said he wants
to be treated like aaron rodgers
you know when you're going to cut a
receiver he wants you to ask him
which is really
you know it's he's a star quarterback i
mean that's what those
how those guys get treated so i think
it's incredible that they got here
i think rogers is the quarterback of the
packers for one more year
and maybe he retires next year maybe he
goes somewhere else
uh his future remains a beautiful
mystery which you know we're all okay
with
not every quarterback is aaron rodgers
or tom brady
but they're obviously seeing what tom
has done
in tampa bay how has tom brady's control
changed how other quarterbacks perceive
theirs to come after him
yeah i i do think that's something
that's had kind of a trickle down
and which it's fascinating to me because
you know i covered the patriarchs for
three years and
i feel like i'm pretty in tune to what
new england is like
and brady never got say in new england
he would joke about i'm just a player
you know and they trade do things like
trade dion branch before the season he's
one of his best friends and his best
receiver i mean that's
you trade richard seymour i mean
everybody was tradeable in new england
and they consistently won and then you
get to tampa and they bring in
two of his friends antonio brown and rob
gronkowski
uh and then they win in tampa also now
one takeaway is that tom brady's a very
good football player
and makes other people very good but i
do think
seeing brady have sane personnel let the
other quarterbacks to go
well hang on a second maybe i could
write my own ending
and maybe i could bring in my guys and i
you know i think russell wilson thought
about it i think
aaron rodgers thought about it the other
hand quarterbacks generally are very bad
at this
because they want their friends rather
than
what's best for the football team so it
is something to sort of be careful of
but i think everybody took notice of
what brady did
i mean it reminds me of the old days
with bill parcells wanting to shop for
the groceries and
was that shop for the groceries and cook
in the kitchen or something like that i
mean and
a lot of people have said coaches aren't
good at personnel decisions either
and a lot of them aren't and it's the
same sort of thing though because like
you know we see it in the draft room all
the time you know except for a couple
teams that have very coach centric
drafting like the bengals are kind of
like that
um most times when coaches get involved
mistakes happen you know when
when quarterbacks get involved
mistakes happen because they want their
friends or they want their friends to be
paid or you end up overpaying or like
you know so that's sort of the slippery
slope of this thing is that
you know quarterbacks are generally very
good at playing football and not very
good at doing personnel
personnel guys are very good at
personnel and not good at playing
football everyone should sort of stick
to that
but i think brady ended up blurring the
lines a little bit
ian rap report joins us here on the rich
eisen show i'm susie schuster in florida
just uh just not to interrupt you or
anything but just so you know i'm
standing in the jets building right now
so if i have to run away for a
meeting with a coach or something it
will not be because i don't like you
it'll just be because i have to leave
just
what if it was because you didn't like
me that would be awful and very awkward
have you ever had anybody hang up
mid-interview um
have i chris oh on monday we had the
power go out so the interview got cut
off but that was about that's pretty
good
we had someone get
midway through an interview on abc
sports does that count
it's pretty good and i chased him down
and i asked him two more questions
before we got to the locker room
that's i mean i feel like that's pretty
good the fact that he stopped again to
answer your questions
he didn't stop some level of respect but
he didn't stop we ran
ask gary thorne will tell you sometime
it's a great story live on television
that was great
because i think he dropped a little
sexual harassment crap and i and i
said oh yeah it was it was it was my
carrie bradshaw moment that's what mike
taurico refers to it but yeah
nobody i don't think hey hey hang on one
second i'm sorry
oh but how exciting would it be if maybe
it's like a signing so that rich doesn't
have to cry into his pillow tonight
yeah ian where's zach wilson i'm sorry
i'm back now
okay where's zach wilson is it zach
wilson it's his uh
it's not zach wilson but the problem
with this time of year is every phone
call could mean
breaking news so you have to get every
phone call so i apologize but i'm back
now
no i think it's kind of working exciting
it makes for a question this is
great who was it ian uh grocery source
postmates knowledge of the situation
but how cool would it be if it had been
something really big it's almost cooler
that it wasn't
it's just the rich show we're very
mellow here we're very chill today
i mean i uh yeah one time i hung up on a
radio host in washington
and he ended up absolutely destroying me
the next day until i called up and
apologized
and then he had to go to break because
he was so flustered when i called up and
apologized he didn't have anything
planned except just to trash
oh that's amazing that's more like
boston sports radio where the minute you
hang up they'll trash you how are they
gonna trash you for just doing your job
that's so bizarre
i mean people have i get people there's
all sorts of reasons to bash me you
don't i don't need to give people
reasons they got plenty of reasons
i'm not in the interest i have zero
interest in bashing you in fact
i just really care about who called and
and and what just happened but that's
neither here nor there if i break the
story i will let you know that it was
the call that i took
that'd be that would be helpful if you
could please just credit the rich eisen
show first and make sure you're
at rich eisenhower so he doesn't feel
left out because rich gets very pissy
about this kind of stuff
hey i nobody knows it better than
me so when is zach wilson showing up
though ian
i don't know let me see if i see him
do not see him you know one thing that
is funny with training camp is like we
spend so long you know i work from home
usually so i spend so long trying to
figure out like
who's showing up where who's holding out
but like for training camps you just
reporters just wait in the front and
they're like oh that guy walked in
like the best way of reporting like i
see this guy um they're still in a
stalemate
uh i don't know when it's going to end
uh i don't you know it
the problem is you can't predict it
because it's literally someone changing
their mind based on something that they
had
decided right so it could
it could be today it could be tomorrow
it could be in three weeks i mean brian
aral
is the agent uh from wme he also
has had holdouts with joey bosa and
rokon smith
and you know aaron donald so he's done
this before
he could be in it for the long haul with
his client um
he fights he fights very hard for his
guys um
and but i don't you know the end in
sight i don't know because it literally
could change based on one decision
before we lose you to the hallways and
to the parking lots because that is
basically half of what stocking is
for a training camp uh what are your
thoughts on what's going on
down in houston
um i mean it's a little it's a little
awkward
but i don't know like i probably don't
have as many
um problems with it as a lot of people i
mean
it's a player who could be traded who
hasn't been traded yet
who is kind of going through the motions
of practice i mean it's a little weird
but like
deshawn's a professional sounds like
he's been really good in the building
um people are gonna sort of pick apart
all the weird things that happened at
practice
but i sort of don't really care about
all that i mean to me it's more like
are they really going to trade them i
believe teams are interested i believe
teams are still interested even with the
legal issues
hanging over him we'll see if he gets
traded but
to me like i don't think there's
anything so wrong with houston having
him come to practice and
play around like i don't you know
there's a lot of reason to criticize but
like to me that's sort of just like
whatever you know
you think he's going to be in uniform
for the first game
which uniform that's a good question how
about a uniform
a uniform will he be on the field
uh there are like eight possible
outcomes
that's one of them i honestly don't know
i really don't i wish i did i wish i
knew who he was playing for i wish he
knew if he was suspended
um this is one story where there are so
many different outcomes i really do not
know
this is one of the crazier stories i
feel like every year there's one
story that you're just kind of like what
the heck is happening here
and this is i guess this is the story
for the day
yeah it's crazy all right if you see
zach tell him that rich is really
worried about whether he's going to play
or not will you please
gotcha i'll send it i know that's really
the message you want to send as you're
reporting for nfl network but that's
that's that's our priority if you don't
mind no i'm on it i'll tell everyone
here
hey thanks thank you see you later take
care
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here